the difference in right swipes on Tinder
for a guy with a master's degree versus
a bachelor's degree is I want to say 90
more anyone that wants to fact check me
this is in John burge's date Dynamic so
if you've got your bachelor's degree and
you think do I want to stick about and
do this Masters it's a year of your life
it's going to be a bit expensive you're
going to have to work hard but dude 90
better conversions on Tinder for the
rest of your life that's what they
should put on the enrollment thing of
course doesn't matter about the course
you get to have 90 better conversions on
Tinder if like all that these schools
need to do or start making snarky
comments on Tick Tock and promoting
their programs with stats like that hey
if you enroll now and you end up
graduating our course there's a 90
chance that you will get more swipes
than someone who does it come on in I'd
go I would probably do too the only
people that win are the high performing